Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two David P. We will be accepting
congratulations for a billion views through
the weekend. I don't even know what I'm talking
about. You obviously we accept congratulations
any time. Here's an interesting voicemail with
just a really specific logistical question. How
much are people spending for pillows? Because
those my pillow ones are pretty damn expensive.
Speaker 4: Have you ever noticed how expensive
the my pillow pillows are? Right. You
get a pillow like that for five bucks at
Wal-Mart, that's probably better.
Speaker 1:
Yeah. Oh, I guess that's it. OK, I have
no idea how much on my pillow costs,
I know people who spend a lot of money on
pillows, one hundred and fifty two hundred bucks,
and the pillows are tailored for this. That or
the other thing. I'm just an old fashioned goose
feather pillow guy. I like a firm goose feather
pillow. There's like a two pack that I buy
off of the Internet for like 50 bucks to pack
for 50 bucks. Beautiful, perfect pillow for me.
The people saw it. They said, sir, this is an
absolutely perfect pillow for for both reading
and for sleeping. And that's that's what I need.
I have no idea how much the my pillows cost, but
it seems to be making Mike Lendell a lot of money.
We have a great bonus show planned for you today.
China is announcing a limit on children's
online gaming to just three hours a week.
Is this good? Is it an authoritarian
dystopian fiasco? Which is it? Is it both?
We will talk about that. Secondly, you
might if you drive in the United States,
be used to only unleaded gasoline. Of course.
I mean, it always says unleaded, but Algeria
was still using leaded gasoline, but no more. The
world has now rid itself of unleaded gasoline.
Why did it take so long? And what's
the history of that? And lastly,
after getting hit with a Category four hurricane,
New Orleans is facing weeks of power outages. I
have been to New Orleans in the summer. It is
not a place you want to be without power in the
summer and therefore without air conditioning. We
will talk about what's going on there on today's
bonus show. Get instant access. I invite you to
sign up at join Pacman Dot Dotcom. You can use
the coupon code better. Twenty one if you would
like, and if you would prefer to join via Patreon
instead of on our website, you can go to Patreus
Dotcom Slash David Pakman show and get access
to the very same bonus show. I will see you
then. We are here all week otherwise tomorrow.